may ask you some questions please sure
okay fantastic
i'm scared oh there's everybody wins
don't worry um all right
so could you could you please i win uh
could you please pick three fingers
and tell me what they are uh your thumb
okay
your uh pinky okay and your middle
finger okay
so could you please pick uh two fingers
your middle finger and your pinky okay
could you please pick one finger
uh i'll go with the middle finger okay
could you please pick one finger
oh pinky okay let's play again can you
pick one finger please
[Laughter]
uh your middle finger okay can you pick
one finger please
your thumb yeah your pinky
okay now pick uh two more fingers please
your uh
middle finger and your uh ring finger
okay
could you please pick one more finger
damn it so
i thought that and hence the illusion of
choice
it's the illusion of choice if i'm
asking
the questions provided i ask the right
questions
there can be no correct answer it
doesn't mean that
ultimately if if that's what you wanted
let's say like i thought i was guiding
you to something i wanted it turns out
that was the outcome you want to
well let's now let's here's now i'm
going to ask the wrong questions i might
not get what i want so
by the way sorry to interrupt uh for
people that might be just listening to
this
that uh no matter what trajectory we
took through that decision tree that
ryan was presenting it was always ending
up with a middle finger ironically
enough
i was surprised so and all of us were
surprised
and we were both winners yeah we all
everyone was i i
felt like a winner all right so now it
now i'm gonna then i'll ask some
different questions if you don't mind
uh can you please pick two fingers to
put down
uh your middle finger and your pinky
all right oh that's so awkward that's
like the worst finger positions
okay can you please wait a minute that's
oh hold on
yeah well what if you pick two other
fingers to put down
uh you throw me a pinky okay my thumb on
my pinky can you please pick two fingers
to put down
well whatever two you like okay your
middle finger and your pointy finger ah
okay can you pick two fingers to put
down
what's the name is index finger index
finger that actually the point
one that's the one we usually point it's
weird to point with the ring finger uh
sorry what do i put two more to put down
please
uh the middle finger and the ring finger
ah man
is it what if you pick my my ring finger
and my index finger
yeah yeah i win yeah so even though i'm
asking the questions it's not impossible
that i arrive at a good outcome for me
but it's no longer guaranteed i went
from a situation where i
literally can't lose yeah it's pretty
low probability
right super low probability and the
second you realize what i'm doing you
would never let me win
because the ball is truly in your court
so i guess that that's kind of what i'm
fundamentally trying to put into play
almost all the time
can i ask the right set of questions can
i develop the ability
um skills wise understanding wise and
then discipline wise
and then have the courage and the
constitution and the and the discipline
necessary the patience necessary to
ask the proper questions and wait for
the proper answers
and if i can
all assuming like the perfect world
i went period oh yeah so does that make
sense yes it totally makes sense
you